nande
やったんですけれども8次あるのは一応僕の書いた曲で
えっと中学ができ何を考えていってどうな大人になりたいと思って同種等でを目指した
かそれを曲にしました聞いてください
ブーブー言っは
でもう一度ね逆ですけどクォーツ今では完成です
pou dou dou
隠れ中核に取り返しとけるほどく
針を考える加え me
ブーブー1期3期進まフェアーし
ブーバー新作ねん
1回なんかびっくりする私何を
とりあえずもっといいました f とか言ったの
こだわる女と恋バナとか
あってくれないお前はね大塚えっなんていうこと関係ねーだろこいつは栄誉を持った
クラブだと思う
音一わかんねー
らいべーと聞かれましてご存知初れてほしい
グンナー生姜系はこれがドップ沿ってやると何ペア
夢の中ね舞い戻る後さは衣服やドストレート
ベリーはので気楽
ブーバーし
それじゃいるがだ希望はも触れた相当ぞ
そして of 曲全部不況だ
まるでくらいと言うようだとオレ何したい奴が版つ持ってるよ違う
pou dou dou
ブーブー言っキプロス pou dou dou
そうよしんば変化0以前教えたら今日はよろしくお願いします
ちょっと見たら負け
さてえっと今回僕は唯一の学生スピーカーとして学生じゃねえな東大生スピーカーと者
がしてもらうんですけど
最初に生んで木刀大嫌いなんですよね
えっとああ
なんでかっていうと最初はすごくエキサイティングなと思ったんですでもなんだろ
すごいんだろうなぁと思って入った学生の多くは
いう点数とって良い学科に行っていい
企業に入って安定した生活を送ることかなんかオナニーみたいな学生団体に入って
イノベーションだのなんかすごいことをやれたと言ってるような奴ばっかで様子見
面白くなかったんですね
で
どうして
その中でも僕が一番から多くと相容れないなって思ったことがいいかって
セラなんだろ解約すが極端な公立志向を持っていてそれパーティーだったり音楽だっ
たり
一見無駄なんだけどめちゃくちゃ大事な文化的なものというのはすごい馬鹿にすると
いうか切り捨てて傾向にあるということそしてもう一つ自分のコミュニティの外の人
たちの理解は今日が限りなく1いうこと
ああどうでこんなもんかーって思って無駄をとことん追求できるはずのこの
アカデミズムの現場で効率主義に走り
いろんな世界を見てよの世界に対応できるする
用意するはずのこの際語学の歯がこんなにも排他的で閉鎖的なのか
これやべえなって思って僕ももうなんかどうでもよくなっちゃって学校に行かないで
種苗のクラブでバイトしてみたり旅でてみたり
各ないがでイベントをオーガナイズしてみたりなんかそういう事ばっかやったんですね
で
敵機が訪れたのが去年圧でして来ははさえで東大ディスるアップ後のをやろう
そうなったんです
えっと当然セットすごいなんだろ女だったりとか
失敗しちゃった人がもっと中 twitter とかでグチグチグチグチネチネチ言う
夏ばっぱ好きなんですけどそれすごく蘇生待って待って
じゃあなんか堂々とコアはさえっていうステージの場で壇上に上がるして堂々と1対1
で戦わせたら面白いんじゃないかしかもヒップホップ都市の文化までそれってすごい
熱いんじゃないかそう思って灯台クリエイティブシューターバスキャット企画として
これはやることがありました
東大と対極のコミュニティーという雰囲気の川崎の工業地帯の
ラバーたから結構いる間積載ファーっていうところに行ってきて
主催者も0くって優勝で話した結果東大生ラッパー体感先のラッパーということで行っ
てみようとなりましたね
ってこれが高天斎のラップ当てる東ガス
can you do
何種所で消えてるようなお前あの
ブーブー言っはそりゃあヌー
仕事して頑張ってとわかるかなそれはっそうやって経験でも経験値も頑張るしかないん
だ
超だちょっからハッカーから放っなったけどまぁ員それぞれ脳やは両手上げて毎日
頑張っ
ている情報 is バージョン
ブーブー hb いっぱ
padre も思い切っぬ富士
use our まあイメージっ夏いいハーレロスパだぜ立ってりゃ分かる
お茶1曲解で大整備たてからパリぷよそれ
ケタ背少んだろかかってきなって一茶俺だがキーまっ
まあその見ての通り結果は大成功だったんですよね
あの一件は違うでセールやってるこのラッパってるって実際はさんはラッパーの人生を
すごいリリックに込めて相手に重いキューブつけるもので
この曲が終わった後すぐ東大生1人スコアハ喋ったことないと思うんだかめっちゃ反射
かれたんですけどよーくこんな企画やったって
hip hop やってる奴ってすごいなんか中途つで
伝法で金もなきゃいけがってるよねはずだと思ったけど全然言葉の重みが違う
っていうか島の sl 言葉買ってちゃねみたいな
あっ
行けるんだ
東大生カルチャーの力を使えば東大生のこれを届くんだ
まだまだ当然面白く的じゃん
そう思ったんですよそれかじるともうすごい俺は目が高まってきてナンパ買ったんです
けど
この曲を通じて俺のやりたいことが決まりました
争奪ストリート答弁を爪 go
ラプトからカルチャーを通じて当該製
ストリード好きになってもらおう
ストリートってもともとすごい自分を解放して知らないとたちと話し合い
笑い合いまた次の週から生きていくためのエネルギーをいるそんな場所でもあるんです
ここにいるには全然肩書も年齢も肌の色も何も可愛い関係ねぇ
ただそこにいる奴らぜいなくなって誰もが一体となって感動を共有できる
そんな平等な場所なんです
もしこの場所で
遠田みたいで社会で影響力を持ったコミュニティーと
アングラで熱い想いを持って築き上げようとしているあいつらをつなげばもっともっと
日本は面白くなるに違いない
そう考えて僕もラッパーとして活動を始めて雇いまあその東大生の中でラップが好きな
人とかを集めている
東大サイファーというかを主宰しています
こうして活動を進めていったんですけどいろんな人が話して家
さっき言った東大生のつまんない所ってもしかしたら
悪渋谷とか出るなどのイノベーションとか目指してる人たち家族に意識高い系のいても
少し当てはまる部分があるんじゃないかと思ったんです
総合しかしたら僕の話を聞いてるあなたちゃん中にはいるかもしれ
テクノロジーによる効率化ん
その過程でイノベーションのあまり奔走するいやそれは言いですごい良いことが
だけどその途中で
人間の梱包にあるカルチャーそれは無駄だと思って切り捨ててませんか
イノベーションでハァハァたちが貸してあげたい未来はそれは誰がものですか
アナたちが見えてると思ってる世界
もしかしてその先にもっと広い世界が山ほど広がってるんじゃないですか
もっと披露してね日本全然フラットができないか
学歴とか社会地域とかそんなんも全然関係なく面白いやたら同士をつないで面白いこと
ができる場所を作れないか
コミュニティの壁を取っ払って好きな dope な音楽とかカルチャーの中でっ
酒を酌み証
語り合いん面白いなって思ったことができる
そんな場所を作れないか
そのとき思ったのかシュガーの c1000地区でした1年生の頃僕が
渋谷がそのダンスクラブでアルバイトしてたんですけどその時にその場所ってへ
ベンチャーの社長だったり登壇して撮ってるそれからまた
ストリートがカルチャーにどっぷり浸かったアングラーのやつからもう予熱が詰まった
んですけど
そこを中心として彼らをつなぐ生態系を作れないか
でもあそこが遅くってすごいラブホテルが多いというか
近寄りのなくてオープンな空間に失礼
確かにそうだでも逆に
あそこなら僕の一つをリノベーションしてヒップホップがカルチャーだったり
それでもどんどん出したゲストハウスチェーンコミュニティスペースみたいなものを
作ったらどうだろう
そしたら面白いんじゃないかな
弟ストリートにも共通するんですけど汚くて危ない場所って実は人間そのものが一番
見える場所だと思っているんです
もっとオープンな空間そう考えたらもっともらう方は一番素直な自分を出せるかもしれ
ん
そう思って実刑的にしゅべラブホプロジェクトっていうのを始めました
僕がラボが好きなのもあるんですけど
でも突然た方はか偉いなって思って
とりあえず試し品が低レートをやってみようと思って今棄却しています
あるフロアヒップホップあるフロアハウスあるフラーロックスターにして部屋ごとに
ラッパーとか dj がパフォーマンスしている区
ちょっとだけエロい区
なんかエロいキャラその日刷りの a ちゃんがいるとかじゃなくてその空間として
エロいっていうことなんですけど
軽さにどっぷり浸かって同プランが聞きながら酒飲んで散るしてその中でいろんなこと
をかけた人が何も関係ない方でそんなイベントを作りたいなと思っています
とりあえずまた得ます公立浣腸流って長いもあると思うんですけど社会化が図れるかな
からも
カルチャーとかようまくとか遊び心そんなことがすごい今
軽視されている献上
そして無意識のうちに社会が解消化された結果自分の所属するコミュニティの中でな
価値基準みたいな判断基準からすごい一元化してる消去
そんな日本って俺は今すごいやばいなって思っています
だからこそまだと言われるカルチャーん
そういうものに行ってコメンテーター壁をぶっ壊していっ
ふらっと行く代わり braver を作らないか
そしたら日本ってもっと面白くなるんじゃないですか
そう思ったんです
最後に川崎なラッパ
川崎サイファーから今日はらぽさんに読んでいて
0ピースくん全巻をお願いします
me
というブーツ
pou dou dou
一熱いサティ橋梁チャッキーちょっブーブー言わ here
の西野拒否しの母のトリトリも取り合ってるでしょ
ユーザーすっごく遊びとかそうか俺が聞かれるぞとパケたもう袖たからだからいる上
波止場まで半ばオーナーいい
ブーバーしコロパキッズ4やてぃくそー今日ドゥ
エピキーポルあーれた週刊考慮パティまあ市玖島
ブーブー hani ことは絶対からキュウビからそこで patti patti
patti 三上ねそうじゃ
ここ地雷プレイヤー中核製と癖ていいかどう内装でステージ女性的性質や武器で住む村
ボード前これは当然ストーリ空想だろう8までぜーんぶウソだろってかを積んだよ
やっぱ心がある
ちょ watch 中心ちっはパティたフォトば
ブーブーウオッチャーパティ大きい
パイパンヌード
やっぱり半端じゃないよタイムショッカーって言わないそこでか回すだけだろう
あたらか干されだけ空晴れさせるだけならば別掛け流し
つまり y らが市でも3角からそれだったらてなって運命の悪戯
ブーバてるは黒いたよ
ブーバパイパンヌード言葉
2 s てペペパーリーそうしてペーターちっそしてここに聞いて空想ぴぴキビキビ1
まりパティシェしおりますありがとうございました
ん